formerly a green lantern and hal
jordan's mentor Sinestro once said that
order came only through fear when his
tyrannical abuse of power was exposed
Sinestro was banished to the antimatter
universe there he forged his yellow
power ring one that channels not build
power but fear now leader of his own
Lantern Corps
Sinestro seeks to bring his vision of
order to the universe and vengeance upon
all Green Lanterns the fearsome tyrant
is a blaster using will as a resource to
terrorize and finish off weakened prey
his passive is yellow impurity Sinestro
skills mark targets yellow impurity if a
target is marked Sinestro Corps skills
receive a powerful bonus effect use
saw-blade to hurl a jagged construct
bling dealing power damage to the first
if marked by yellow impurity the target
takes additional power damage equal to a
percentage of their missing health reap
enemies with dread site dealing power
damage to all targets in a wide comb
this marked by yellow impurity enemies
are also silenced use coal the weak to -
to a target location and deal power
damage to all nearby enemies when
Sinestro kills an enemy champion the
cooldown on coal the weak is reset if
marked by yellow impurity enemies are
dealt additional power damage Sinestro's
ultimate is fear incarnate as a
skill-shot he launches parallax the
living embodiment of fear it's parallax
hits an enemy champion they're stunned
and delta power damage for the skills
duration during this time nearby enemies
are feared away from the primary target
and marked with yellow impurity if no
champion is struck
parallax creates an area of effect that
applies fear steals power damage and
marks all enemies with yellow impurity
because Sinestro has low health and high
damage victory will come from knowing
who to engage when to engage and how to
use his different skill combos when
playing in Lane saw-blade followed by
dread sights will silence your enemies
and create safer trades if starting a
combo with dread sight you sacrifice the
silence from yellow impurity for more
damage with saw blade or cold the weak
more specifically dread sight followed
by saw blue is good at securing a kill
on low-health targets keep in mind saw
blades damage
captain targeting drones when possible
thrown the map to ambush low health
enemies or move to flank weak champions
during teamfights for instance if two
enemies are in lane and one has low
health ambushed with coal the weak and
quickly finish them with saw blade the
kill will reset coal the week's cooldown
allowing a timely escape or aggressive
repositioning if escaping you can drop
fear incarnate just beyond the enemy's
vision around a corner this way fear
incarnate will be waiting on the ground
as their enemies round the corner and
run straight into power damage and
appear immediately turn and unload an
area of effect combo if you secure a
kill use cold weak to escape preferably
over a wall use this tactic with caution
however as sometimes it's best to save
fear incarnate for teamfights
Sinestro benefits the most from
artifacts that grant bonus power damage
rushing tier 2 of dr. Destiny's dream
stone helps your early Lane presence by
providing sustained will next the power
penetration from cosmic belt or book of
eternity is often essential as enemies
will counter build power armor neurons
contract is also very useful as it
provides great defensive stats and the
blood bargain active skill which suits
Sinestro skill set
Sinestro psychic assault slows a target
and shreds their attack and power armor
this allows you to single out and soften
a target during surprise attacks or
teamfights teach fools the meaning of
fear at Sinestro tyrant of Corrigan